[موسيقى]
انها الثامنه بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر
بتوقيت الرياضه نصائب شراير وهذه اخبار
الساعه
ماسك اصحاب العلامات الزرقاء في تويتر حتى
العشرين من ابريل الجاري اما الدفع او
ازاله التوثيق
اوكرانيا
وتستعد لعبور نهر دينيبرو والقرم تتاهب
في قضيه الوثائق المسربه
المعلومات السريه يتداولها الاف الموظفين
في
الامم المتحده تراجع وجودها في افغانستان
بعد منع طالبان النساء الافغانيات من
العمل بالمنظمات الدوليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام في اخبار الساعه
اذا انقلى ملك شركه تويتر ايلون ماسك ان
المنصه ستزيل في العشرين من ابريل علامات
التحقق الزرقاء بتويتر لمن لا يدفع
الاشتراك واعلنت الشركه في وقت سابق ان
الاشتراك في الخدمه سيكلف 8 دولارات شهريا
للمستخدمين الذين يشتركون عبر الموقع واحد
عشر دولارا شهريا لاولئك الذين يشتركون في
تطبيق ايواس وكجزء من نظام التحقق الجديد
سيقدم تويتر علامات ذهبيه للشركات ورماديه
للكائنات الحكوميه والمؤسسات الاخرى
وزرقاء للافراد سواء كانوا من المشاهير ام
لا
ينضم الينا من
عبر سكايب الدكتور احمد بن نافع استاذ
الهندسه وامن الشبكات في جامعه سانخسي
الحكوميه الدكتور بنافع اهلا بك معنا ابدا
معك من التساؤل الذي يراودنا من من يملكون
العلامه التوثيق الزرقاء على تويتر ما
الذي سيحصل اذا لم ندفع في العشرين من
ابريل الجاري
الكلام
انه في يوم عشرين عشرين اربعه وهذا يوم
مخصوص هنا في في امريكا بالذات في
كاليفورنيا لانه يوم
ايش معناها يعني حتى اختيار وكان غريب انه
يختار يوم 20/4 انه اللي حيحصل انه حيزيل
هذه العلامات اللي ناس ما دفعوا لماذا
تاريخ العشرين هو يعني تراه يعني تاريخ
مميز في امريكا لماذا اختيار هذا التاريخ
بالذات العشرين من ابريل
هو هو يعني يسمونه عيد المسطولين فاعيد
ماذا اي نعم الناس اللي يحششوا في يوم
عشرين اسمها فهو هذا اختياره اختيار غريب
حتى الوقت انه اختار هذا هذا الرقم فهو
معروف عندنا هنا في كاليفورنيا في امريكا
انه هذا هذا التاريخ مش يعني اختيار غريب
انه يختار يحدد فينا هذا نهايه الوقت
للعلامه الزرقاء نعم طيب لا اعلم كيف يمكن
التعليق على هذا الاختيار على هذا التاريخ
الحقيقه يعني لم استطع تمالك نفسي من يعني
لم ادرك انك يعني ذكرت هذا المصطلح بالذات
ولكن طيب
كيف سيتم الدفع طيب للذي يريد ان يحافظ
على علامه التوثيق الزرقاء برايك هل سيكون
هناك استجابه لهذا القرار وكيف سيتم الدفع
في شركات كبيره شركات كثيره وجهات اعلام
كبيره والبيت الابيض نفسه اعلن انه ما
حيدفع يعني بما فيها
الواشنطن والجماعه دول واحنا ما حنتفاعل
مقابل انك انت تديني العالم هذي فما حيكون
وسيله له انه يضغط عليهم الفكره ما فيها
اخص وهي بالفكره ما فيها ايه انه هو الان
بيحاول انه يدخل يعني مداخيل للشركه لانه
المعلنين رفضوا تماما حتى كان في مؤتمر
قبل كم يوم كان في فلوريدا ما قدر يقنعهم
انهم يرجعوا مره ثانيه الى تويتر بسبب
تصرفاته فهذا هو السبب انه بيلجا الى
مصادر اخرى نعم طيب ولكن دكتور بنافع ماذا
لو نفذ ماسك وعيده وازال العلامه الزرقاء
علامه توثيق لمن لا يدفع بالفعل كما ذكرت
يعني هناك مؤسسات كبرى مثل البيت الابيض
والواشنطن رفضت هذه السياسه ماذا عن بقيه
الافراد اذا لم يلتزموا هل حقا الحسابات
في مواجهه ازاله التوثيق حقيقه ام لا هذا
مجرد ضغط من ايلون ماسك احتمال كبير انه
يعني يختار مجموعه منهم ويسحب منهم
الاشاره زي ما عمل مع يعني عقب نيويورك
تايمز لانها رفضت وهو عنده مشكله مع فممكن
يختار مثلا الناس يعملوا منهم امثله على
انه اذا ما تدفع هيحصل لك مثل الشخص هذا
والشخص هذا لكن في نهايه الامر انت مثلا
لو تشوف تغريده من جهه وتحب انك تتاكد هي
صحيحه او لا شوف عدد المتابعين لما يكون
بالملايين تعرفوا ان الشخص هذا هو الشخص
الحقيقي نعم طيب هل ستفقد علامه التوثيق
الزرقاء خصوصيتها او هيبتها لانه المساله
صارت متعلقه بمن يدفع لانه في الاعلان
واضح انه هناك يعني من يدفع الاشتراك
سيحصل على علامه توثيق الزرقاء بغض النظر
اذا كان من المشاهير ام لا هل برايك علامه
توثيق ستفقد ميزتها
نعم صحيح هذه نقطه مهمه جدا لانه اصبحت
الغرض هو المال قصه الاشاره
الزرقاء هذه من يعني من 2008 حصلت مشكله
وقضيه فبناء عليها تويتر صار يدي العلامه
الزرقاء هذه حتى يتحقق من الشخصيات لا انا
اصبحت للبيع فما اصبحت اي نوع من الميزه
لها بقدر ما انه انت يعني انت من ناحيه
نتحقق من شخصيتك بس ما في لها القيمه
مثل الاول يعني انه الشخص هذا مهم شكرا
جزيلا لك على كل هذه التوضيحات من دكتور
احمد بن نافع استاذ الهندسه وامن الشبكات
في جامعه سان خوصيه الحكوميه
[موسيقى]
من تويتر نذهب الى الحرب في اوكرانيا
بموازات المساعد دبلوماسيه المستجده
لايجاد مخرج للحرب الاوكرانيه تتواصل
المعارك دون توقف على العديد من الجبهات
لكن هناك تحول رئيسي يلوح في الافق على
ارض الميدان يتمثل بتحول اوكرانيا من
الدفاع الى الهجوم هذا ما يشير اليه
مسؤولون موانا لروسيا فيخرسون فقد اتهموا
كييف بالاستعداد للهجوم عبر نهر الحديث
نقله القائم باعمال محافظ القطاعه المحافظ
المقاطعه عفوا التي اعلنت روسيا ضمها
والذي قال ان وحدات من الجيش الاوكراني
تقوم خفيه بنقل القوات والمعدات الحربيه
وتجميع الزوارق المائيه وذلك استعدادا
لمحاوله عبور النهر
وفي الاثناء تتاهب القوات الروسيه في
القرم لهجوم اوكراني وشيك في شبه الجزيره
بحسب مسؤول الروسي وفيما يجري الحديث عن
هجوم محتمل في خرسون والقرم شنت القوات
الاوكرانيه هجوما في مقاطعه دونيتك وذكرت
مصادر بالمقاطعه ان الجيش الروسي تصدى
لهجوم اوكراني المعاكس باتجاه جنوب
المقاطعه المصدر ذاته اشار الى القضاء على
عدد من المقاتلين الاوكراني
هذه التطورات تاتي لتزكي اخبارا اخرى تشير
الى ان كيف تجهز نفسها للمبادره الى
الهجوم فخلال الاسبوع الماضي اشارت وكاله
رويترز الى ان اوكرانيا قامت باعداد
وتجهيزه ثمان وحدات اقتحام هجوميه اطلق
عليها اسم الحرس الهجومي ووفقا لزعيم
مجموعه فاغنر العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
فان هذه القوه قد تضم حوالي 200 الف عسكري
اوكراني
اما فيما يتعلق بالمعركه الابرز والاطول
معركه باخمت فان الزحف الروسي لا يزال
متواصلا في اخر التطورات قال رئيس مجموعه
فاجنر ان قوته باتت تسيطر على اكثر من 80%
من المدينه من جهتها اوضحت وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه ان وحدات من قوات الانزال الجوي
تقدم دعما لفصائل باجنر من اجل السيطره
على وسط المدينه مشيره الى ان القوات
الاوكرانيه باتت تتواجد فقط في الجزء
الغربي منها
معنى من دنيتك مراسل العربيه رائد الاغبر
رائد ما حقيقه هذا الهجوم المضاد الذي
تشنه القوات الاوكرانيه في جنوب دنياتك
تطويق مدينه في دنيتك بنجاح ما المقصود من
التطويق بنجاح والى اي حد هذه المعركه
مهمه بالنسبه لدني للهجوم المضاده الذي
تشنه اوكرانيا
فعلا يعني
محور الاكثر سخونه يوم امس واليوم حتى
اكثر سخونه من باقي الجيش الروسي يطوقها
من ثلاث نواحي على نفس شاكله باخمط ويبقى
المحور الغربي لمدينه طبعا المدينه هي تقع
شمال غرب دانياس وبالتالي هناك يعني حضور
لسلاح الجو الروسي بكثافه وقصف لمواقع
القوات الاوكرانيه واستخدام لاسلحه متطوره
خلال يومين كان هناك اصرار من قبل الجيش
الروسي على اقتحام المدينه حتى الان لم
يستطع خلال اشهر طويله جيش الروسي من
اقتحام المدينه لكن هناك محاولات يعني
متعدده ومتكرره الاقتحامها وتسجيل دخول
للقوات الروسيه الى هذه المدينه والمدينه
المتاخمه لها ومارن كتقدم بها جيش الروسي
اليوم سيطر على احد بلدات في عجاله لو
سمحت المعركه كذلك الاطول في اوكرانيا في
الشرق الاوكراني
اخر التطورات لديك من هناك من معركه باخمت
اهم اعلان هو للسلطات الاوكرانيه الذي
قالت للمواطنين ان لا تستغربوا اذا افاقوا
على انسحاب الجيش الاوكراني من باقمت لان
وضع القوات الاوكرانيه صعب جدا لكن بالفعل
هناك مقاومه اوكرانيه هناك امدادات ما
زالت تصل من طريقين وليس طريق واحد من
التشاسوفيا المحور الغربي ومن المحور
الجنوبي الغربي حيث مدينه قسطنطينه جيش
الروسي حاول اقتحام وقطع هذا الطريق لكن
لم يفلح خلال الساعات الماضيه هناك سلاح
جو روسي يحلق في سماء باقمه باسم التمرار
ويقصف وهناك عمليات عسكريه من اجل اكمال
السيطره على باقمت في الايام القادمه صهيب
رائد الاغبر مباشره من دنيا
اكد المتحدث باسم مجلس الامن القومي
بالبيت الابيض جون كيربي انه لا توجد اي
مؤشرات على تقديم مصر اسلحه فتاكه الى
روسيا كيربي قال ان مصر شريك امني مهم
لامريكا في المنطقه وانه توجد علاقات
دفاعيه طويله الامد بين الجيشين المصري
والامريكي ياتي ذلك بعد ان زعم تقرير
لواشنطن بوست لان الوثائق السريه اشارت
الى تقديم مصر صواريخ جراد الى روسيا الا
ان الخارجيه المصريه وصفت التقرير بالعبث
المعلوماتي
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه في ظل التوتر في
بحر الصين الجنوبيه الولايات المتحده تبدا
اكبر مناورات عسكريه مشتركه مع الفلبين
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الملفات المسربه من لا
تزال تثير ضجه واسعه وتشغل بال اطراف
متعدده تساؤلات عديده تطرح حول كيفيه تسرب
هذه الوثائق في انتظار الكشف عن نتائج
التحقيق والذي قد يستغرق اسابيع هذا ما
اكده مسؤول امريكي في تصريحات لشبكه سي ان
ان حيث قال ان التحقيق في تسريب الوثائق
المسربه قد يستغرق اشهر وذكرت صحيفه ان
التحقيق سيحاول تحديد النطاق التسريب سيما
وان المسؤولين لا يعرفون حتى الان ما اذا
كانت هناك المزيد من الوثائق المسربه التي
لم تنشر بعد واوضح المسؤول ذاته ان
المعلومات السريه يتم تداولها عبر الاف
الموظفين في الفانتا
ونبقى مع مساله تسريب الوثائق من
الفانتاكون فقد شددت وزاره الدفاع
البريطانيه على اهميه توخل القراء الحذر
في التعامل مع الادعاءات التي من المحتمل
ان تنشر معلومات غير دقيقه حياه التسريبات
لاستخباراتيه الامريكيه واشار متحدث
الدفاع البريطاني على حسابه في تويتر ان
هناك مستوى خطيرا من عدم الدقه في
التسريبات مؤكدا على اهميه الحذر في
التعامل مع المزاعم التي لها قيمه ظاهريه
والتي من المحتمل ان تنشر معلومات مضلله
هذا وكشف موقع اكسيوس الامريكيا مسؤولا
اسرائيليا اكد بان واشنطن تواصلت مع
اسرائيل بعد تسريب وثائق عن دعم المصاب
للاحتجاجات مشيرا الى ان واشنطن نصحت
بلاده بعدم المبالغه في رد الفعل على
تسريب تلك الوثائق السريه هذا وكشف الموقع
بان اداره بايدن حاول الطمانه المسؤولين
الاسرائيليين في الايام الاخيره لان
واشنطن ملتزمه بعلاقتها الامنيه مع
اسرائيل بعد التفاصيل الوارده في مجموعه
من وثائق البانتاجون السريه والتي من
شانها ان تزعزع العلاقه بين امريكا
واسرائيل
[موسيقى]
مياه بحر الصين الجنوبي تعيش حاله غليان
في ظل توالي المناورات العسكريه فبعد
المناورات العسكريه الصينيه الاخيره في
محيط تايوان جاءت دور هذه المره على
الولايات المتحده لاستعراض قدراتها والرد
بطريقتها الخاصه على الولايات المتحده
اختارت الفلبين لاطلاق اوسع مناورات
عسكريه مشتركه في تاريخهما وتحمل هذه
المناورات اسم ملكاتان وتعني جنبا الى جنب
باللغه الفلبينيه وتتضمن هذه المناورات
استخدام طائرات مروحيه عسكريه وتدريبات
قتاليه اخرى بجزيره فلبينيه تقع شمال
البلاد وتبعد نحو 300 كم فقط عن تايوان
وستشمل المناورات ايضا محاكاه لعمليه
انزال برمائيه على جزيره بالوان القريبه
من جزر سبراتليز المتنازع عليها بين
الفلبين والصين وهناك مؤشرات عديده تجعل
من هذه المناورات استثنائيه من بينها
مشاركه 18000 جندي واطلاق نار بالذخيره
الحيه للمره الاولى فضلا عن استخدام
صواريخ
وعاده الفلبين الى واجهه الاحداث بعد
ابرامها مؤخرا اتفاقا يهدف الى تعزيز
الوجود العسكري الامريكي لديها وبموجب
الاتفاق سيسمح للقوات الامريكيه باستخدام
اربع قواعد عسكريه اضافيه من بينها قاعده
بحريه قريبه من تايوان ويسمح الاتفاق ايضا
للجيش الامريكي بتخزين المعدات والامدادات
الدفاعيه في تلك القواعد كما ان البلدان
استانفاه الدوريات البحريه المشتركه
بينهما في بحر الصين الجنوبي
هذا واصلنا موقع
مقارنه بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
والصين كقوتين عسكريتين في ظل الاجواء
المشحونه بين واشنطن حول مساله تايوان
الولايات المتحده الاولى عسكريا على مستوى
العالم
اما الصين فهي الثالثه
سر التفوق الامريكي يكمن في اربعه عناصر
سلاح الجو والموارد الطبيعيه
القدره اللوجستيه والموقع الجغرافي
سلاح الجو الامريكي يضم
13,300 طائره سلاح الجو الصيني لديه
3248 طائره
بحريا الصين تتفوق على امريكا بعدد السفن
الحربيه
لكن قوه حاملات الطائرات الامريكيه تقلب
المعادله
اما لوجستيان فالتفوق الامريكي واضح
امريكا لديها 35 ميناء وثلاثه عشر الفا
وخمس مئه مطار اضافه الى قواعد عسكريه
امريكيه منتشره في العالم
الجيش الامريكي حاضر في اليابان وكوريا
والفلبين والسنغافوره
[موسيقى]
اكدت مصادر العربيه ان السلطات السودانيه
القت القبض على شخص هدد المبعوث الاممي
للسودان
بالقتل وكانت البعثه الامميه في السودان
قد دعت السلطات لاتخاذ اجراءات قانونيه في
دعوات الاغتيال رئيس البعثه واعربت
المتحدثه باسم البعثه مي يعقوب عن تزايد
القلق اذا فيديو متداول في وسائل الاعلام
يظهر رجلا في مناسبه عامه بالخرطوم يطلب
فتوى للسماح له باغتيال المبعوث الاممي
[موسيقى]
والى المبعوث الاممي في اليمن هذه المره
هانس جراند الذي قال في تصريحاته لوكاله
رويتورز قال ان المحادثات العميقه والجاده
بين الاطراف اليمنيه امر مشجع كما قال قبل
ذلك اعلنت الحكومه اليمنيه بدء عمليات
تبادل الاسرى والمعتقلين مع الحوثيين
الخميس المقبل ولمده ثلاثه ايام اشار
الفريق الحكومي بالمفاوضات الى ان عمليات
تبادل الاسرى ستشمل رحلات جويه بين
العاصمه صنعاء وعدن ومناطق اخرى من اليمن
بالتنسيق مع اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر
كما اكد ان الاستعدادات قد اكتملت
وهو طبعا كان المقرر في يوم عشره وتم
تاجيل العمليه الى ثلاثه ايام بسبب
الاجراءات طبعا التي اخذت وقتها نظرا
العدد الكبير عدد الذين من سوف يتم
مبادلتهم تم تعجيل العمليه الى ثلاثه ايام
واليوم الاول سوف يكون
بحسب ما اتفق عليه
يوم طبعا بعد غدا يوم الخميس يوم 13 من
هذا الشهر اول يوم سوف يكون هنالك عمليه
تبادل بين صنعاء وعدن 250 عصير ومختطف
صنعت الجهود الدبلوماسيه الاخيره والحراك
السياسي تفاؤلا بمرحله جديده سمتها او
سمتها الاستقرار وتغليب المصالح على
الصراع السياسي والعسكري
حراك سياسي قوي في منطقه الشرق الاوسط
المتوتره على كثير من الجبهات لاطفاء كثير
من الحرائق التي ظلت مشتعله لسنوات
عاد الضوء الى طاولات الحوار بدءا بتهدئه
التوتر بين عدد من دول المنطقه وتركيا
مرورا بلقاءات بين القيادات السياسيه
وانتهاء بالاتفاق مع انقره على ايجاد سبل
لحل الملفات او تهدئه حده الصراع في سوريا
وليبيا
العاشر من مارس شهد ايضا ولاده لاتفاق بين
السعوديه وايران برعايه صينيه بعد قطيعه
امتدت لنحو سبع سنوات اعطت املا بظهور
نتائج ايجابيه على ملفات عده بالمنطقه
كسوريا والعراق ولبنان واليمن الخطوه
الاخيره في سلسله التهدئه جاءت من اليمن
بعد زياره وفدي السعوديه وعمان لصنعاء
ولقائهما بقياده الحوثيين وبحث الوصول الى
الحل السياسي عبر عده مراحل يؤمل منها اع
الاستقرار الى اليمن بعد ثمان سنوات من
الحرب الدائره هناك
المسارات الدبلوماسيه التي انتهجتها دول
المنطقه صنعت تفاؤلا بمرحله جديده سمتها
الاستقرار وتغيب المصالح الاقتصاديه
والتنمويه على الصراع السياسي والعسكري
ولقيت اشاده دوليه واماميه
التقى ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن
سلمان في جده عضوه مجلس الشيوخ الامريكيه
السعوديه انه جرى خلال الاجتماع استعراض
وعلاقات الصداقه بين البلدين وعدد من
المسائل ذات الاهتمام المشترك
[موسيقى]
وبعد قليل في اخبار الساعه اضراب الاطباء
في بريطانيا يؤجل
30000 موعد وعمليه
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اطلقت امانه منطقه
المدينه المنوره اعمال المختبر المتنقل
الخاصه بفحص جوده وسلامه الاغذيه والمياه
للتاكد من خلوها من البكتيريا المسببه
للامراض ومطابقتها للمواصفات بهدف ضمان
سلامه وجوده الغذاء المقدم لاهالي وزوار
المدينه المنوره طوال شهر رمضان ويضم
المختبر المتنقل اجهزه حديثه لفحص المواد
الغذائيه في وقت قياسي
[موسيقى]
سلامه الاغذيه والمشروبات اولويه تزيد
اهميتها خلال شهر رمضان وفي خطوه للحد من
تلوث الاطعمه فعلت امانه المدينه المنوره
المختبره المتنقله للتاكد من سلامتها هو
عباره عن سياره مزوده باحدث التقنيات لفحص
الملوثات الميكروبيه والكيميائيه الموجوده
في الاغذيه يتم فيه فحص تقريبا 1500 تعينه
في الشهر يتم سحبها عبر فرق رقابيه مختصه
احضاره للمختبر يتم عليها عمل الفحوصات
اللازمه لكل نوع الهدف طبعا من المختبر
المتنقل هو
الحفاظ على سلامه المواطنين والزوار
وتوفير الامان الغذائي لهم اكثر من مئه
عينه تسحب يوميا من 50 محلا تجاريا للكشف
عليها ويضم المختبر المتنقل اجهزه حديثه
لفحص المواد الغذائيه في وقت قياسي وضمان
خلوها من البكتيريا المسببه للامراض
ومطابقتها للمواصفات
بمجرد سحب العينه
ووضعها في الجهاز يعطي نتائج سريعه ودقيقه
طبعا احنا قلنا بحملات توعويه وضحنا لهم
الطريقه السليمه لتنظيف الايدي وزعنا
عليهم معقمات خمسه اختبارات يجريها
المختبر المتنقل مثل الكشف عن عناصر
الحديد والكبريت في المياه اضافه الى
السموم الفطريه ومتبقيه المبيدات في
الاغذيه والهدف حياه امنه غذائيا لسكان
وزوار المدينه المنوره من المدينه المنوره
سلطان السلمي العربيه
اطلقت اليوم رئاسه شؤون الحرمين الخطط
التشغيليه الثالثه للعشر الاواخر من شهر
رمضان وذلك بعد نجاح الخطتين الاولى
والثانيه وتتمثل الخطه في رفع مستوى خدمات
ضيوف الرحمن من سقيا وعمليات تنظيف وتطهير
المسجد الحرام وتجهيز المصليات التوسعه
واتاحه اماكن مخصصه لذوي الاحتياجات
الخاصه وتقديم خدمات الاعتكاف كما تشمل
الخطه تكاملا بين الوكالات والجهات
المسانده
من مكه المكرمه معنا مباشره مراسل العربيه
اسامه القاسم اسامه اهلا بك معنا مع بدايه
العشر الاواخر من رمضان ماذا تتوقع
السلطات السعوديه من ارقام للمعتمرين في
هذه الفتره التي تشهد اقبالا ورغبه من
المسلمين في التوجه الى البقع المقدسه
اهلا وسهلا صهيب تحيه طيبه العربيه نعم
أنقل لكم صوت وصوره اليوم من التوسعه
السعوديه الثالثه اكبر توسعات الحرم المكي
الشريف والتي تتسع لاكثر من مليون ومئتين
الف مصلي طبعا نتحدث اليوم عن الخدمات
المقدمه بمناسبه دخول العشره الاواخر
وبدايه الصلاه صلاه القيام من الليله
نتحدث اليوم عن خدمات سقيا زمزم التي
تجاوزت الى هذه اللحظه اكثر من 26 مليون
لتر مقدم نتحدث عن خدمات التنظيف باكثر من
اربعه الاف عامل وعامله في جميع ساحات
ومداخل المسجد الحرام لتنظيف وفرش وتعطير
سجاديد المسجد الحرام نتحدث عن تواجد
ووجود اكثر من
4800 دوره مياه 72 دوره مياه مخصصه لذوي
الاحتياجات الخاصه نتحدث ايضا عن خدمات
الاعتكاف تم اصدار ثلاثه الاف تصريح
لثلاثه الاف معتكف ومعتكفه في المسجد
الحرام وهم يكونون في توسعه الملك فهد
وتوسعه توسعه السعوديه الثالثه نتحدث
اليوم ايضا عن اكثر من خدمه مقدمه كخدمات
ايضا تقديم السقيا تقديم ايضا
الماكولات والمشروبات للمعتكفين بحديثنا
اليوم صهيب عن هذه الخدمات نستعرض لكم
الان التوسعه السعوديه الثالثه وهي تشهد
الان ازدحاما شديدا ودخولا للزوار وقاصدي
المسجد الحرام نتحدث اليوم ايضا عن خدمه
اداره التفويج والحشود التي تبدا من اليوم
مع بدايه الخطه التشغيليه الثالثه بعد
نجاح الخطه التشغيليه الاولى والثانيه
الخطه التشغيليه الثالثه تشمل اداره
وتفويج الحشود بشكل مكثف وتقديم هذه
الخدمات التي سبق ذكرها بشكل اكبر لخدمه
اكبر عدد ممكن من الزوار والمعتمرين اذا
صهيب بحديثنا ايضا عن اعداد الزوار
والمعتمرين اعلنت رئاسه شؤون الحرمين عن
وصول اكثر من 950 الف زائر ومعتمر في
اليوم الواحد بما يعني 19 مليون زائر
ومعتمر تقريبا الى هذه اللحظه توقعات ايضا
بان تزيد اعداد الزوار وقاصديه المسجد
الحرام في الايام القادمه بحكم دخول
العشره مليون معتمر وزائر في اليوم الواحد
في رمضان
هل من يعني مع هذه الاجراءات والخطه
التشغيليه للعشر الاواخر هل هناك توقعات
او كم سيكون الرقم المتوقع للزوار في
العشر الاواخر اسامه
نعم صهيب العشره الاواخر في الحرم المكي
تشهد دائما تواجدا اكبر من عدد الزوار
المعتمرين غير عن العشرين اليومين العشرين
الايام الماضيه اذا بحديثنا اليوم عن هذه
الخدمات تتاعم توقعات تشير الى وصول
الكثير ايضا من الزوار والمعتمرين اكثر من
الاعداد الموجوده هناك بعض الايام حصلت
اعداد الزوار المعتمرين باكثر من مليون
زائره معتمر مثلا في الامس وصلت اعداد
الزوار المعتمرين الى اكثر من مليون
وخمسين الف زائر ومعتمر وبالتاكيد انه
الايام الايام القادمه والتحديد بالعشره
الاواخر استشهد الزياده كبيرا نتحدث ايضا
اخيرا صهيب عن الخدمات المتواجده في
الخدمات الصحيه والعلاجيه والانسانيه هناك
تكثيف لنقاط ومناطق الطوارئ في المسجد
الحرام لاستقبال الحي اي حاله وثم نقلها
الى مستشفيات الحرم ونقلها الى مستشفيات
مكه المكرمه التي تشهد هذه الايام يعني
استقبالا كبيرا للزوار المعتملا وجهازيتها
الكامله التي اعلنت عنها في وزاره الصحه
منذ بدايه شهر رمضان المبارك اليوم وانا
اقف الان في هذه المنطقه اشاهد الكثير من
الزوار المعتمرين ياتون من داخل من خارج
المسجد الحرام نتحدث ايضا عن خدمات النقل
هناك اكثر من ثمانيه الاف حافله تردديه
لنقل وايصال الحجاج والزوار والمعتمرين
اسامه القاسم مباشره من المسجد الحرام
[موسيقى]
قراراته طالبان المثيره للجدل قد تدفع
بمنظمه الامم المتحده الى مغادره البلاد
فالمنظمه الامميه اطلقت مراجعه لعملياتها
في افغانستان وطلبت من جميع الموظفين
الافغاني عدم القدوم الى العمل على الاقل
حتى شهر مايو المقبل والسبب وراء هذه
الخطوه هو قرار طالبان منع الموظفات
الافغانيات من العمل مع المنظمه بعدما كنا
قد منعنا من قبل للعمل مع جميع المنظمات
غير الحكوميه هذا واتهمت البعثه الاماميه
بافغانستان طالبان بارغامها على التخلي عن
الشعب الافغاني وهو ما يتعارض مع مبادئ
المنظمه كما شددتها المنظمه على ان
السلطات طالبان تتحمل اي عواقب سلبيه
لتبعات قراراتها على الشعب الافغاني
[موسيقى]
اصحاب الستره البيضاء يطلون مره اخرى
باضراب واسع يشل حركه قطاع الصحه في
بريطانيا الاف الاطباء الشباب باشروا
اضرابا يمتدوا لاربعه ايام للمطالبه برفع
الاجور بنسبه مرتفعه تصل الى 35%
ويعد هذا ثاني اضراب كبير يهز الخدمه
الصحيه في بريطانيا في غضون اشهر بعد
اضراب الممرضين وموظفي القطاع نهايه العام
الماضي هذا وابدت الحكومه انزعاجها من هذا
الاضراب حيث وصف وزير الصحه ستيف باركلي
الاضرابات بانها مخيبه للامال للغايه وقال
ان طلب الجمعيه الطبيه البريطانيه غير
معقول لانه سيؤدي الى حصول بعض الاطباء
المبتدئين على زياده في الاجور تفوق 20
الف جنيه استرليني وكانت لهذا الاضراب
تبعات سلبيه على الرعايه الصحيه في
بريطانيا حيث ادى الى تاجيل 350 الف موعد
طبي
[موسيقى]
اخبار الساعه تاتي اليكم تذكيرا بابرزها
ماسك يمهل اصحاب العلامه الزرقاء في تويتر
حتى العشرين من ابريل الحالي اما الدفع او
ازاله التوثيق
اوكرانيا تشن هجوما مضادا جنوبا وتستعد
لعبور دهن نهر دينيبرو والقرم تتاهب
في قضيه الوثائق المسربه مسؤولون امريكيون
يكشف المعلومات السريه هي تداولها الاف
الموظفين في الفانتا
الامم المتحده تراجع وجودها في افغانستان
بعد منع طالبان نساء الافغانيات من العمل
بالمنظمات الدوليه
شكرا لكم على المشاهده المزيد دائما على
العربيه دوت نت وعلى صفحاتنا على مواقع
التواصل الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات